[TYPEWRITER  NOISES]
RETO MEIER: Hello, everyone.
My name is Reto Meier, and
welcome to This Week in Adroid
Development for October
15th, 2012.
This week's challenge for
regular viewers, figure out
which of these shots are live
and which are green screened.
Last week in Android
Development, we celebrated
tablet week, by releasing new
promotional sections in Google
Play to highlight great
tablet apps.
Developers can check out the
Android Developer blog to
learn more about building
quality tablet apps.
If you want to skip the
unwrapping and jump straight
to the juicy marrow, check out
the tablet app quality
checklist to feed on the
knowledge of what it takes to
build an app that's designed
for the growing number of
Android tablet users.
We're all about quality here
at Android Developer
Relations, so we've also
released these Core App
Quality Guidelines, a checklist
for your release
process that will ensure your
apps delight rather than
disappoint.
Continuing our tablet theme
this week, Nick, Roman and
Adam talked responsive design
in Android Design in Action.
If designing for tablets sounds
like a lot of hard work
for an undetermined gain, check
out these developer
stories detailing how
mint.com, TinyCo and
Instapaper took advantage of
the tablet opportunity.
We spoke to the development
teams behind all three apps on
last Thursday's Developers
Strike Back.
Check out the YouTube video to
learn how these developers
overcame the challenges to build
successful tablet apps.
On last Friday's App Clinic, we
once again tried to review
video play apps CineXPlayer,
MX Player and DicePlayer.
Sadly, the sheer overwhelming
anticipation of this long
awaited broadcast resulted in
an unprecedented demand from
viewers tuning in live, which
may or may not have caused
YouTube service to spontaneously
combust.
It was only after we'd completed
our greatest ever
live performance that we
realized that not only had we
not be broadcasting, we hadn't
been recording, either.
Determined never to be defeated,
we'll be trying this
one more time, broadcasting at
the special one-off bonus time
of 11:30 AM Pacific
time this Tuesday.
Meanwhile, undeterred by our
repeated failures, Nick,
Roman, and Adam will be
broadcasting their UX
make-over on two of the video
players we seem entirely
unable to review live on the
App Clinic on this week's
Android Design in Action.
Then on Friday, Ian and I will
once again tempt fate and the
gods themselves, as we attempt
to broadcast the App Clinic on
Friday morning, this week
looking at shopping apps.
After the YouTube servers were
brought back to life last
Friday, Ian joined the
indomitable Dan Galpin for the
Friday Games Review.
Dan will be back again this
Friday, with an as yet
undetermined sidekick, for
another episode of the Friday
Games Review.
As always, you can catch our
weekly Office Hours in London,
Mountain View, and Sydney.
And as always, you can find all
of last week's shows and
the schedule for this week at
Google Developers Live.
That's Developers.Googl
e.com/live/Android.
In breaking news this week,
the long-awaited and much
anticipated new Google Play
Developer Console was released
today for everyone's
app analysis
and publishing pleasure.
You can log in and check it out
right, or check out the
post on the Android Developer
blog to find out more details
before taking the plunge.
In other developer news, last
week saw the launch of free
trial periods for In-app
subscriptions.
That's all in Android
Development news this week.
As always, we look forward to
you joining us for our many
live shows.
And remember, before you
came into my life, I
missed you so bad.
My name is Reto Meier.
Thanks for watching.